and I literally ran into the back of the
garden of the house there's a woman in
there with her daughter and she screamed
because just imagine this big six foot
two guy just ran inside your house at
this point I should have just given up I
don't know what I thought I was doing
but then they broke in the door the
officer gave me one punch I think that's
the hardest punch I've ever felt like
hit me to the floor and they just
started beating and yeah I mean
[Music]
Bobby where did you grow up and how was
your Early Childhood
um I was born in Congo a Democratic
Republic of Congo known then as Zaire I
came to the UK
um age three grew up originally
in college for like the first maybe year
in Britain and then where I mainly grew
up was a Peckham Southeast London on a
Gloucester estate and what were you like
as a kid
um I was energetic
um I was chatty
um quite intelligent I was always in the
top set in school very good at football
um for in year four as you played for
the year six team
growing up in Peckham
um at the beginning was fun I was
oblivious to where exactly I was I grew
up in a closer state but at the time
when you're
seven eight nine years old you don't see
the crime you just see older people
hanging around in the streets we don't
know what they're doing but we used to
go outside every summer play football
running around and the transition was
when they knocked down across the state
in 97 we moved to the new sort of
buildings with meant to be much nicer
which it was in terms of appearance but
that's when I moved into year seven and
that's when I started finding out oh
this is where I am in Peckham so the
gangs the crime the violence you you
become more aware of it you were
recruited by the Peckham boys can you
speak about how that kind of first came
to be yeah I mean with the Peckham was
it was a thing that where my older
brother was quite an affiliated with him
already
and he's come back home tell me stories
and he used to think well who's these
guys because everyone had nicknames so
it's like the Avengers or the sort of
Mutant hero Turtles whatever it is so it
was literally I was still kind of
wanting to play football so year seven
year eight and the majority of year nine
I kind of kept away from that I saw them
I thought it was cool people and I
of known to quite a few of them but
nothing where I was kind of involved it
was an incident one day I bought well I
say board I took my brother's happy
about his knowledge and
um I was walking down the street heading
home and where our house is by the pick
and post swimming pool library is where
everyone hangs around so we live just
under the house the new build houses
there and I was walking by one of the
Peckham boys um came over said oh let me
see that usually when someone says let
me see that hat or let me see that phone
whatever it is they're trying to rob you
and I'm like no you can't see the Hat
what are you doing and he's like give me
the Hat then someone else who knew who I
was came over and said are we doing
that's Carly's little brother he's like
oh I didn't know oh you're one of us man
and that was my recruitment process so
the next day when I'm walking past
you're like where are you going come and
literally I was like packing away from
there for anyone who might not know can
you just kind of explain like what the
pecking boys are and kind of how the
gang structure in like South London
works yeah I mean the African boys were
um
wait people don't like to say the word
gang but it was a gank
um we used to run around terrorizing
other areas other areas running around
trying to terrorize us the older lot and
this hierarchy so there used to be the
PMS which is the peckamans then it was
the ypb which is the young Peckham boys
then there was a wire wire PB which I
was part of was just a younger younger
pecan boys and even goes down to the PKS
at the time which was the picking kids
and some of the stuff we would do at our
age was very trivial stuff like with
your petty Street robberies and then
you'll sell drugs for the old a lot and
they will go to places like debt for the
new cross have been for the Ghetto Boys
from there and then I think as you get
older that's when the criminality is
what it changes it becomes more serious
uh mainly my thing at the time was
robbing phones we used to go rubbing
people's phones and you'll get about 80
pound 100 pound of phone so as a 14 15
year old that's a lot of money I can go
now and buy the latest
um Night Train as well as before it's my
parents will buy me that one pair
trainer which I would have had for the
whole year now I can go and buy three
four without their their kind of
knowledge so I wouldn't say was making
crazy amount of money but it was money
indeed when we kind of got to like 16 17
that's when you start selling drugs and
with that you're kind of making a bit
more money so you may be making like 400
500 pound weekly kind of thing yeah
for me the crime sort of escalated I
tried to go to college so many times so
my first year I went to Richmond
um college and studied a level with four
a levels because of my behavior and
stuff had issues with my parents at home
and then I left and I was 17 at the time
and I remember I was playing for fish
athletic at the time The Knack would
just fish FC but fish athletic at the
time uh got a part-time job at peacocks
and then was also selling weed so I was
doing all of those things at 17 by
myself living living on my own and it
just became too much so something had to
go and it was um Education First I quit
education at the time
um I quit my job at peacock because I'm
trying to concentrate on football and
selling drugs
and they just came to a point one day
one of my friends told me I got a
security Evan robbery and I was okay you
know what's that all those people carry
the suitcases with the money I said I'm
not doing that that's crazy I can
understand that little things we do but
you're telling me I said no I'm not
doing it
the next day he went and done it and he
came back with ten thousand pound in
cash and I was like that's the first
time I've ever seen that amount of cash
and then my head was spun when
everything is going
I remember in 2006 I started wanting to
get back involved in football I kind of
stopped and I signed for um ilford um FC
I was playing the reserves first team
Reserve first team reserve and I was
doing quite well um I was getting a lot
of goals and then I remember at the time
um a guy a gentleman called Mark Butler
from Ashford Town Middlesex uh signed me
and I remember I was making my debut for
Ashford Town Middlesex and we're going
to play against folks in FC and on this
Friday I met with some old friends from
Peckham who's also doing the robberies
they had planned a robbery the next day
with one of my friends Javari Creighton
and I said yeah now I can't come and
make my debut they're like you surely
yeah you guys go
the next day um I'm on a coach with my
team javar will call me that day in the
morning and he said oh I've done the
robbery but I think these guys are
trying to bump me and I tried to bump
you out he's like
um
with I've done a robbery where they
saying that their money is not in
there's no money in there but I'm trying
to call them and they're not answering
and so on so he's like I can see them as
well they're trying to pretend they're
not there so he said I'll call your
brother see if you can sort out so I
tried to call my brother said oh let me
see what I can do but I think your voice
was quite impatient and he's gone on
there and had an argument with him and
one of the guys I've ended up stabbing
him
so I remember one of the guys
um that I knew called me said
oh my God oh my God I think Jafari is
dying I think his javar is dying I'm
like what you mean he said he's on he's
on the floor just being stabbed his eyes
are not open his eyes are closed now I'm
kind of facing Two Worlds because this
world where I am right now is the
football world where I'm not involved in
any crematic no one knows about my
history or background and now this is
kind of infiltrating
my reality right now so it's like I'm
trying to
keep calming and people kind of looking
around because I'm kind of shy now what
you mean he's dead what you mean he's
doing so people looking around like
what's going on and I'm saying look call
the ambulance hold it and just make sure
you call the ambulance so I I kind of
hang up the phone in my head that you
know what the ambulance has come he's
made it he's alive and everything is
going to be cool once I finish the game
we lost free one that day I made my
debut
uh but as soon as I switch on my phone I
saw so many messages and missed calls
and voicemails and I just knew I just
knew so before I came to listen to them
I'll call my brother my brother's like
oh I'm sorry man I'm sorry and I just
knew that your boy had been killed
whatever's called me up don't go to
Mom's house and pick him armed police
are here looking for you so I'm freaking
wild and at this point I had like lots
of
items in my house but I didn't know the
police didn't know where I lived so um I
just panicked though so I called a girl
that I was seeing at the time as well
said don't come to my house quickly I
just powered
um all the new clothes and everything
into her house all the money into it
put it all in bean bags told her to take
all the drugs that I had that was
starting to sell again pull it all in
there she took them then I went over to
my mum's Who's down the road and see
what the commotion was and like there's
a helicopter there on police there and
I'm kind of content like ah guys
um I'm who you're looking for I'm Robert
kasenga they like move move it I'm like
no I'm the guy you're looking for it oh
get down
machine guns and get down get down get
another put me on the floor had my hands
behind my head and then um got me out in
the office I came over and said yes
we're resting your suspicion of murder
I'm like what murder for what they
taught me to
um police station in um South London
Wolfeboro police station
and at that point that I was still being
quite arrogant because I'm like you guys
got the wrong guy just wasting my time
you're wasting everyone's time here then
two other officers approached me and
they said um we're from flying Squad and
we're resting you forever conspiracy to
rub that's where my heart sunk I was
like
yeah yeah because I was definitely
involved in robbery so but the next day
when they're done all the interviews the
robberies they brought up had nothing to
do with me I'm like oh
yeah all that these robberies guys said
on this day on this day I was here I was
there nothing to do with me so I was
released
under on bill on the investigation but
at that point I shouldn't have just
stopped that it's hot but at that point
like you said you're also used to the
money and then I continue to do the
robberies and then on the 13th of March
we went and done a robbery uh rains Park
train station
um 27 000 pounds from the Station train
station was robbed and ended up getting
cool
and that's when everything kind of
changed I remember I was hiding um
I was a Gateway driver with two young
people we robbed the train station
making our way back home
um as I got to Wimbledon uh The
Wimbledon area
um I think someone has supported a car a
police officer started walking towards a
car then I was a police officer at first
he's walking walking all of a sudden
he's trying to open my door like police
open up that I sped hit the car in front
of me run around drove
and what I used to do
um I always used to wear dark clothing
as old rules but underneath I'd wear
sort of bright colored clothing also of
like a football jersey whatever so my
whole thing was that if I had to discard
my clothes and all of a sudden they're
looking for someone dark clover but now
I've got bright color clothing and I'm
running in football gear they stopped me
oh no I'm just a jogger that was my kind
of plan but anyway I ran um into some
garden and hit there for ages I remember
there's a police um helicopter up and
down and in my head I was like ah
my Miss is going to be it's called me to
go and pick her up but let me just stay
here then at one point
I could hear that
snuffling or something like sniffling
like what's that enough well I don't
know there's a dog in his garden and I
looked up and as a police officer of his
radio and he threw his dog over and I
literally ran into the back of the
garden of the house there's a woman in
there with her daughter and she screamed
because just imagine this big six foot
two guy just ran inside your house at
this point I should have just given up I
don't know what I thought I was doing I
ran upstairs and barricaded myself in
the in one of the bedrooms of the
bathroom I can't remember and they're
like open up open up I'm not trying to
use all my shrimp I'm like really truly
where the hell am I going but then
they're broken the door the officer gave
me one punch I think that's the hardest
punch I've ever felt like hit me to the
floor and they just started beating and
I mean and I was just like say I want to
sue the police I mean and then they had
their dog like this big work right like
my arms all that even to this day I've
got all the scars and this was like the
big puncture there like the dog was just
chewing my arm and that I like the dogs
chewing me through me he's buying me
they're like shut up they're kicking me
and I always thought I'm gonna sue the
police for this but I thought actually
end of the day you run into someone's
house the police don't know if you've
got weapons or not so their first thing
is let's protect this family so
by every means that had the right to to
beat me up but then I went to
um they took me to the police station
and had to take me to the hospital to
get a tetanus job then went to the
um
went to uh
um Court the next day and then I was
reminded they told me reminded I was
gonna get about like now you're being
reminded I broke down in tears I never
cried so much I was like I was
hyperventilating and all that what you
mean you can't they said you're going to
throw a mother and at this point you're
hearing all this violence that goes on
and felt and I was like how has my life
turned out like this
I was intelligent in school
I was in the top set I was good at
football just signed for Ashford town
what am I doing going into prison I just
couldn't sort of have him like what have
you done with your life they gave me
like two or three different sentences
which alsoever ended up me being in
prison for eight years can you just kind
of speak about your experience of being
in prison yeah I mean uh prison was
tough in regards to
just being away from your friends and
family and not being able to do the
things you wanted to do you can see
people going out and enjoying themselves
and just stuck in your store especially
in the summer I was always quite
entrepreneurial so um every prison I
went to I was kind of the go-to guy I
opened up a betting shop and a bookies
and a casino and the casino was the Big
Money Maker man um I used to have a
blackjack table and literally I would
loan you we used to make
um you can buy a sort of arts and crafts
sort of
um pieces and we used to get the
matchsticks um and that would be the
chips so I'll loan you maybe 50 pound
worth of chips each chip costs five
pound and all you have to do was give me
back my chips and whatever you got on
top that's your profit kind of thing so
that's how I kind of kept myself
occupied while I was in prison but I
also studied so I went and done a degree
in criminology and social policy which
was funded by the open University and
that taught me a lot about myself and
about about my environment
and by the time you got released eight
years later how do you think you changed
as a person yeah so um I was released on
the 24th of February 2015.
and I said what can I do to make sure I
don't go back to jail first thing don't
hang around the same purpose I hang
around with because I looked at it like
these people didn't visit any prison
they didn't send you money so why are
you gonna go back hang around with these
people they forgot about you secondly
spend more time with my family right
because the more you spend time with
your family the more you're gonna be
away from them and thirdly you're just
by trying to
be legit I didn't want I know I knew I
didn't want to go and work for someone
but I'd made plans but initially you
come out of prison you're broke or
making a lot of money in prison I've
come out of prison now I can't make
money I can't go open up a shop or a
betting shop or a bookies so um I
literally went and done a night shift at
a Bagel Factory called Mr Bagels in
Hackney Wick and I remember just working
there using that money to fund a
football club we just go about
fundraising with buckets outside of test
scores I remember a company called age
group was buying Mr Bagels I approached
them and said look I've just come out of
prison I use this job to find my
football club then he started sponsoring
the football club and he put me on a
salary because I was good at marketing
and getting my story out there and
through the back of that um he put me in
a 28 000 pound a year salary like a year
after coming out of jail
and they just build up the football team
over and over again
just knowing
how I was as a young person knowing that
I was so good at football I had
opportunities and I messed up I didn't
want the young people to follow in that
Journey so what more than could provide
them with a platform and we've lived
experience and say you know what you
guys don't have to do this because I
went through this this is a different
angle and for young people how do you
think sport or being part of like a
football club can impact their life
positively I mean sport for me is a
unifier like for example right
we're in Hackney Wick and we provide a
football for the whole Borough we've got
young people who come from homerton from
dalston from Hackney Wick from London
Fields from Store Newton all these areas
don't get along they don't get along at
all but we bring them all together to
come and play football and hoping to
build that familiarity God forbid later
on in life they're both kind of enjoying
ganks right
that can save their lives because if
there's an issue someone said all right
now leave him alone man I used to play
football with him when I was eight week
I know his mom so that familiarity can
also sometimes aid but also just the
opportunity to provide like for example
a tournament I run every year the 32
Barrel Cup London has 32 boroughs World
Cup has 32 teams so my whole ethos why
can't I bring all these young people
from London together who don't know each
other who are scared to go to
neighboring borrowers just because of
these fake borders they said actually
you guys could be friends I have over 25
people that I know that are being killed
some of them didn't reach the age of 16.
so I'm going to be reached the age of 18
some 21 some of them never got to
go on holiday didn't get to experience
having children
my daughters are like my best friends
and if I never had them
I don't know how where I would be what
would motivated me so you
and I think with young people you guys
forget that gank
um era that you have age is only between
18 to about 24. that's a small segment
of your life you still got to reach 40
still got to reach 50 he's still six you
know it'd be a gang member at 60 or you
so the main thing is that don't risk
your life for this small period of your
life when there's so much more life to
live I remember you had the knife in his
right hand so I said to myself
when I turn around I'm gonna try to
deflect the knife
by doing that
as I've done that
he took a step back I just went bang in
my neck